why is a witch's tit cold I've never
understood that either my relationship
with each one of these guards it sounds
that sounds creepy first car I ever
owned was a Baja Bug and built in a Baja
shop in Michigan that was in lieu of my
pay
monks motors and he's still there but
that was a terrible car this is no heat
it menos VW is in the winter in Michigan
a terrible car
my childhood dream car to be honest with
you would be a tank I still wanted
that's all I've ever wanted to drive as
a tank and generally unfortunately as
German tanks had a better style to them
the guys that helped me build stuff said
they just refused to do it I was gonna
buy a British tank everybody even the
police in the local area says we're not
let you drive around here and tank it
because it's unsettling they have a tank
running around especially with my head
in the helmet you know shrieking things
in German I'm currently driving a GTR
and I'm just gonna leave it at that and
it's literally one of the most curiously
intoxicating automobiles I've driven and
I drove it as a test in to buy him the
test mule and I really really liked it
I'm just saying GTR cuz if I give away
the brand you can go what all the other
cars are now they're crying literally my
wife she likes this Nova this badass
Nova and she calls it my wife actually
says this point that's really a guy
magnet is that something you want to
tell your husband that guys are really
hitting on me all day well maybe you
shouldn't drive it without your top on
why why do I need to hear this if I
drove the Carrera GT it looks like money
and I think sometimes women respond more
to boy that dudes probably got a lot of
dough you know but like I said I Drive
around naked because that's the
relationship I have with my automobile
I could have had a short-wheelbase 250
Ferrari a long time ago and about a 330
GT see if you know all these I like the
GTC cos the character in Grand Prix that
played mr. Ferrari drove it up to the
pits always wanted that car and I end up
getting it it's right over there
but the 250 short wheelbase Ferrari I
could have had at bargain prices but the
one that you just can't get is GTO so
the 6463 GTO is that they're just absurd
with 2030 million dollars I don't care
how much money you make you're not
likely to drive that ever so what I'm
thinking is just stealing one to see
more episodes of car collectors
subscribe to GQ calm
[Music]